Elon Musk announces plan to remove the
block feature on X in violation of Apple
and Google Play Store guidelines I
genuinely do not understand why Elon
Musk would want to remove the block
feature he says block is going to be
deleted as a feature except for DMs he
says it makes no sense
I don't know it makes a lot of sense
what do you guys what do you like why
not just mute no because block stops
someone from basically stalking you but
then they just make a fake account in
stock you then I'll block that one too
but then they just make another one and
I'll block that one they make 50 more
and you're busy but then that makes so
much time and I'll block them every
single time I think it's better to mute
someone and they don't know they're
muted so they can scream but see they're
a prominent high profile people with
millions of followers who don't make
fake accounts and their job exists to
stalk your Twitter take you your tweets
out of context and insult you and Samira
make money off it I'm gonna make it
harder for them by blocking them so now
they'll have to make a fake account but
many of them do not do it